there's a line that some conservatives
have used in recent years that is not
true they'll say look we hate second
wave feminism that's the bra burners of
the 70s that second wave feminism was
bad the Third Way of feminism which was
I don't know it was like the 90s 2000s
that was also bad and now I think we're
in the fourth wave I don't know we're
the 50th wave whatever wave we're in
that's also bad but this is what they
would say they'll say the first wave
feminists they were really good it was
first wave feminists back in the 20s
they were the good ones and it's not
true they're all the same people they're
all the same feminism is just bad okay
it's bad because it it posits and this
is the same issue that we see with
transgenderism it posits a false
anthropology it suggests that there is
no meaningful difference between men and
women